lots of sunshine out there this morning
as we look out over the north valley boy
it is nice a beautiful morning north
vegas you're up in the upper mid to
upper 40s downtown at 50. upper 40s in
the northwest side of the valley
summerlin at 46 the lakes at 48 43 at
mountains edge right now see these
numbers are really pretty normal for uh
mid-mar first of march as we finish off
february yesterday we finished the month
at 76 degrees so that's why the mornings
are a little bit milder it is a little
chilly down st rose parkway red rock at
37. here's what's going on for our week
as we head into the new month warmer
days in the 70s even to low 80s this
week a huge warm-up so fast and then a
slight chance of rain breezy winds and
much cooler temperatures as we get to
the end of the week and especially into
the weekend it'll be a system that drops
out of the pacific northwest right into
the desert but for now we're protected
with a pretty good ridge of high
pressure new orleans beautiful weather
today for fat tuesday but the northwest
inundated with so much rain and there
are flood watches and warnings in
central washington right now even
avalanche warnings across parts of the
mountain ranges with so much snow that's
falling they're expecting several feet
of snow over the next several days we'll
stay warm we'll stay protected with this
ridge and temperatures keep climbing
we're looking for 78 degrees today our
normal high is 67. we're going to beat
that for the next several days and the
numbers keep inching their way finally
into the low 80s with the help of some
southwest breezes on thursday boy that
is going to be the peak of this warming
trend then the numbers fall right back
to below normal even into the weekend
we're looking at low 60's chance of
showers it's not a big one on friday and
even lesser one on saturday and look at
those more those
temperatures in the 60s with mornings
back in the 30s wow quite a change